the Joe Rogan experience it's just like
alright if you want this and then what
happens if one let's say wonder where
we're to win which I don't think he is
unfortunate let's say I don't you think
I'm on the ceiling you know I just yeah
I think there's this kind of dare until
dick cried a little bit right now hard
dick riding on kabhi til there's a few
guys DC always Connor always always
always
Brian Ortega I took right Mighty Mouse
for sure yeah you do dick right that guy
I think he's not wait forever I think
he's the best I mean I mean that's fair
he needs a guy to challenge him you
think fighting so hooligan who I love to
who table it's like that [ __ ] you guys
hate [ __ ] money
that shit's ridiculous I mean so who
does a beast no doubt about it and I
love what so who'd ohdid against Wilson
Hayes over holy [ __ ] this is like a
different so he looks like a karate
champion yeah I get all that do you see
what Mighty Mouse did yeah it went right
through him oh oh you're back out cool
what he did yeah oh you like to clench
check these out detective Olympics
that's very cool check this neon sir
needs the body is fat I grabbed him once
just joking around plan he hit me in the
body with the knee so fast but refusing
it was a confusing where'd that come
from
like I go supposed to go that quick like
they're supposed to be I see you move I
get to think this might come my way
here it is no it was already there
different before I realized he was doing
it he's so [ __ ] fast why and did do
we know why the TJ fights aren't going
down dude I don't know but that one bums
me out that was that is a that's a
[ __ ] gigantic super fight like why
wouldn't he take that fight well first
of all Mighty Mouse right now is
rehabbing a shoulder surgery so it's
gonna be a while he was doing those you
know that Bo thing they do that flexi
thing yeah he was doing some of those
exercises the other day on Instagram I'm
looking at him like okay that's a guy
that's got like he's got some scar
tissue to work out like that's not
that's not healed up did he get surgery
enough yeah he got surgery mm-hmm so
he's out for a little bit and TJ pride
doesn't want to wait I don't know if
that's what the case is I don't know
what the case is in
I mean shoulder surgery six months I
mean so you wait three months then you
have a three month camp you know I mean
if they want announcer yeah right no I
mean I don't even know you can't even
say that because Mara you might not be
able to go if you Matt Hume and Mighty
Mouse are about as smart as it gets when
it comes to preparation correct so
there's no way they would take that
fight of his shoulder wasn't a hundred
percent any fight and risk his legacy
cuz he loses that fight he was like
toldja and he wouldn't go hard early to
test it he would let it look at what
Whitley's been out a little bit because
of his shoulder yeah yeah yeah he was in
here like right after got it he said he
can heal up quick yeah and he might PRP
all that yeah he's gonna do all the PRP
you know there's as much you know
different therapies cryo I'm sure it's
probably still takes a while even with
all our advances now after yeah not now
he's forced to fight and I I see what
the UFC is doing where they do in turn
belt between kholby and dos Anjos where
the you know it's interim bail so now
Woodley you literally have to fight the
winner of this you have to fight him
it's a very sneaky may have a belt what
do you do you want super fight nope this
guy's a belt I get both sides if it's
dos Anjos dos Anjos beats colby dos
anjos lightweight champion now
welterweight champion that's me oh great
great
if I have dos Anjos sitting there with
two belts on his shoulders I mean and
then what do you do with Danny let's say
he for whatever reason walks do Wonder
Boy which is you know tough to do but
say walks doing which Woodley you know
struggled a little bit walks through
them and one of those the number one guy
now Darren till jumps up to number one
or is doesn't work that way because the
the ratings are [ __ ] screwing man all
there sometimes I see a guy who beat a
guy and then the guy who he beat is
still ranked ahead of them they're a
nightmare all they are all the ratings
do now it almost hurts if you're a guy
like Sean Shelby or Dana trying to make
these matchups because guy who's that
fourth it hey what in fight seven he's
like no he's seven have nothing to gain
from that where before I was like he
wants you to fight this guy he's a name
he's on seven fight win streak we don't
know what ranking is but we know he's
damn good guys were more willing to take
it now they nope he said
I want a number one
[Applause]